[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous devez la virer c'est interdit c'est
une travailleuse handicapée quoi non
n'importe quoi ah non non tu rigoles
c'est pour ça que j'étais embauché
Hubert et j'ai pas de voiture bonjour
venez ses parents ont dit que si je
sortais avec leur fils il me donnerait
une voiture tu refuses de louer ta
maison mais tu serais prête à leur louer
ton corps un tatouage de Bip Bip et
Coyote dans le dos tu es pas bien placé
pour me dire ce que je dois faire de mon
corps
je vais t'apprendre à t'amuser
tu vas passer ta vie avoir peur de tout
oh
tu sais quand tu as disparu ça a été la
meilleure chose qu'il soit arrivé
félicitations est-ce que Sacha passe
bien au lave-vaisselle c'est un être
humain de quelle blague en Russie l'ont
apporté
[Musique]
j'adore ta maison elle est très
chaleureuse
C'est la fête
faut que tu apprennes à t'amuser
[Musique]